good afternoon everyone welcome to
beyond payments with Android pay I'm
Prakash armani group product manager in
the Android pay team and with me is max
Christophe I lead the Android pay
engineering team it's great to be here
today so as you saw in the last session
for those of you who were here for
Android pay everywhere Android pay is
not just about payments it's about
enhancing the entire in-store experience
sending your card your payment card to
the merchant or retailer was just the
first step but there's more to it than
that when I go and make a purchase in
store typically in addition to my
payment card I also render a loyalty
card a gift card and/or an offer and
that's what we're going to talk about
today so we've got to talk about three
key stakeholders today users merchants
and issuers or banks now for users we're
gonna show you how users can go beyond
payments how easy it's gonna be for them
to sign up for loyalty and most
importantly use it in the middle of an
in-store experience when they need it
most
for merchants we're gonna show you how
they can engage with their customers how
they can contextually send them
reminders and most importantly Max is
going to show you how easy it is for
merchants or developers to add the
functionality to their apps and then
finally they're gonna talk about issuers
or banks we're gonna show how easy it is
for banks to bring to bring Android Play
functionality to their apps so they can
connect with their card holders through
their channels so let's first start with
the pain points what are we trying to
solve here so the average u.s. household
is about 22 ish lul t cards but less
than 45% are active only about 10 are
active that's pretty bad right it's bad
for users because you spent all this
time signing up for that membership you
fill out this long form and then you're
standing in store and you don't have it
when you need it you want to save money
you want to get points and it's not
there with you it's also bad for
merchants are they spending millions and
putting in a lot of effort trying to
engage with their customers continuing
with pain points less than 1% of all
coupons or offers that are issued today
are redeemed
that's pretty staggering it's pretty bad
too and why it's bad for users because
they aren't able to save money again
when they're in line in store for a
purchase because they've forgotten to
cut the coupon clip it bring it with
them in the store when they need it and
it's bad for merchants millions of
dollars are spent every year by
manufacturers and retailers to bring
these offers in front of users so first
we're going to talk about users and how
we address these pain points so
fundamentally there's two things that
users are looking for saving time and
saving money so there's many things
Android pay does to save time first
during payment you just have to unlock
your phone tap and you're done you do
not have to launch any app you don't
have to have the app running in the
foreground you just set it up once and
you tap and the most important thing is
it doesn't just send your payment
credential so as Polly showed in the
previous demo when he tapped on the
walgreens terminal it sent his balance
rewards loyalty card and his payment
card and that does save time because I
don't have to fumble in my wallet find
that loyalty card find their offer and
then presented to the catcher saving
monies the other thing users desire so
the best way to demonstrate this is
actually like walk through a few demos
so for those of you are in the previous
session Polly saved money with his
Walgreens balance rewards card he bought
a pack of almonds he saved $2 I would
also like to save money but before I can
do that I need to add my balance rewards
card to Android pay so to talk through
this demo I'm gonna invite Kate but a
house key
who's senior product manager from
Walgreens up on stage welcome Kate
thanks for cash it's really great to be
here we're really excited to have the
opportunity to need to team up with
Android pay to introduce this new
loyalty experience to our Android users
we cannot wait to share this save to
Android pay email to our loyalty users
who will be able to take advantage of
our simple message tap tap Done
excellent so let's see this in action
can we cast this please great so here's
my email I'm a balanced Rewards member
and I got this from Walgreens I'm just
gonna hit save to Android pay and it's
gonna show you show me a preview of my
balance rewards card I'm gonna confirm
it and I'm done it's that simple so now
when I go into my Android pay I can see
not just my Amex card but also my
Walgreens balance rewards it's that
simple
now when I go and make a purchase at
Walgreens I'd only have to remember
anything I just tap once it sends the
payment tap again it sends a loyalty
card and I'm done
tap tap done exactly we're really
excited that Android pay can make it so
easy for our users to sign up for our
balance rewards program now even more
customers can save and earn points as
they shop at Walgreens
wait this Android Android pay and
Walgreens will be the first first
payment solution and retailer to launch
instant loyalty enrollment thank you
again kid we're delighted to have you
here and delighted with our partnership
with Walgreens thanks so let's switch
use cases so that was a retailer use
case and in-store experience I'm gonna
talk about another use case I'm very
excited about which is in-store dining
so what we want to do is show how
Android pay can go beyond payments for
an immersive dining experience and we're
gonna watch and we're gonna do that
through Z asks so you see these Android
tablets here they're by Z ask which has
these Android touchscreen tablets and
you can find these actually on Chilly's
restaurants today so to talk through
this demo I'm gonna invite variable R
who's the CTO and co-founder of Z ask
and I also want to acknowledge wait Alan
wait can you wave your hand he's the
vice president of digital innovation at
Chili's great leader in innovation I'm a
thrilled to partner with you Thank You
Prakash hi
everyone so at Z Oscar mission is to
revolutionize dining experience and by
partnering with Android pay were able to
bring our brick-and-mortar restaurant
partners into the digital age and
Chili's is a perfect launch partner for
us because they really understand the
value of digital in revolutionising
dining experience for the guests on the
table today we're going to demo some use
cases there are core functionality on Z
ask and how this is all simplified with
Android pay even better than what it is
today right so prior to Z asked if you
went to Chili's you would have to fill
out this eclip first name last name
email address zip cord patil ND very
inefficient as well and then you ought
to give it to the waitstaff would put it
in their pocket and maybe it'll make it
to the manager and maybe he will enter
it into their database system it's not
real time right it's very inefficient so
when we launched the ask services as EOS
we started enrolling for the loyalty
programs at Chili's and we see
enrollment go up by 10 times pretty
staggering number so when we do the demo
you'll see how easy is it with Android
pay it's gonna be even simpler than what
we have done today which is live in the
restaurants so Prakash you want to see a
demo of how to join loyalty program that
sounds great for n so if we could just
focus on the terminal on the right so
I'm sitting at Chili's so the setting is
I'm sitting at Chili's at the table
ready to order my food and on this zr
terminal i see an option to join the my
Chili's rewards program so I'm lazy I'm
not gonna fill out this form yeah I'm
just gonna hit any oil now and all I
have to do as you can see is I'm just
going to tap and as a security feature
I will authenticate
okay so we're gonna tap and as you can
see it sent my information from Android
pay and it's asking for my consent to
send my first name last name email
address so I don't have to do any kind
of typing and I just can continue so
I've given consent for this information
to be sent to Chili's so now you're
seeing the Chili's site and all I have
to do is just enter a pin and I'm
registered so now I have a my Chili's
Rewards loyalty card and I'm just gonna
save to Android pay and there you go
it's always there you don't have to
worry about forgetting it anymore so you
want to log in now
sure so now I've signed up for loyalty
and now I'm going to log in because I
want Chili's to know I'm sitting at the
restaurant and I want them to know who I
am so I'm just gonna hit login and then
I'm just gonna tap boom any point I have
60 points and I'm getting a little bit
hungry I did skip lunch today yep so
let's order some what can we buy for
your sixty points maybe couple of bowls
of chips and salsa won't be enough for
everybody but I think you and I can
definitely hog them up all right so
we're gonna order that we're gonna to
add one plate we're gonna share that
we're gonna send the order and have this
feel something amazing is going to
happen click yes water is going in the
kitchen I just confirm it and boom it
shows up oh my god max you're amazing
it's instant enrollment instant chips
life doesn't get any better
yeah bother I should have mentioned is
if you see anything that excites you
during this presentation feel free to
applaud at any time exactly so Prakash
now we have to show the payment piece of
it also you're looking at me you want me
to pay now yeah I know that's why I
reminded you so one of the most
important thing that z oz does in a
restaurant is pay on demand right you
don't have to wait for your waitstaff to
bring in the check on the table so we're
gonna show how that becomes a lot easier
with Android pay
so Prakash you want to follow through
sure so I'm gonna select pay and all I
have to do is tap
and as you can see my bank from America
MasterCard payment was sent and I'm
going to sleep on I'm going to select a
higher tip because because I percent for
max okay so let's let's go yep let's go
generous and we'll tip this amount I'm
just gonna sign and guess what for
receipt I'm just gonna select the email
option submit number on a digital dining
experience thank you for that thank you
very much okay so that covered the user
section and now I'm gonna turn it over
to max who's going to talk about
merchants and developers great thank you
very much so last year we showed you
save to Android pay we're excited to be
announcing some major enhancements based
on your feedback so first we heard you
we've added safe to android support
directly from emails and SMS messages
we're allowing with these mechanisms to
allow to have brands have a richer more
immersive experience helping you
increase engagement with your customers
let's go back to that chilis demo you
saw that Android pay prompted Prakash to
sign up for that loyalty program and
offered to pre-fill his data to make it
super easy how do they build that well
it breaks down to three easy steps step
one Chile set up a loyalty program in
our merchant console that's where they
defined what data they need to collect
to enroll a new customer name phone
email address that kind of stuff and
they set up branding for their program
and their card art next they made a few
simple changes to their existing loyalty
signup site slighly they wrote a few
lines of code to generate a save to
Android pay deep link and at the end of
their signup flowed they just redirect
to that link Android pay takes care of
the rest I'll show you what this looks
like in practice so the key thing here
is that ultimately we're just going to
create a link and the link will encode
everything in it that we need to trigger
the save to Android pay experience so
now here's the code so
this is the start you saw that Android
pay prompted for Kosh to sign up and
where does that data that prefilled data
come from well their signup webpage is
going to receive the prefilled
parameters in the URL there's such a
standard HTTP GET type of stuff that's
going to be encoded in there
HTTP of course Chili's going to create
the loyalty counter system however they
would normally do that and we come to
the fun part Chili's is going to create
a loyalty object then they're going to
turn that object into a JSON web token
this gives us a signed a serialized
representation of that loyalty object
and finally Chili's is going to generate
a deep link from that token that they
can use from multiple channels but let's
go deeper so this is what the loyalty
object creation code looks like all we
really need from you is about eight
pieces of data and we show you how to
plug them in here points and balance
your class ID this comes up when you
create this loyalty class in our system
it's an active loyalty state an account
ID a name again just fairly boilerplate
stuff you just drop the code and the
data in here and then you build and you
have your loyalty object so now we're
going to turn that object into the JSON
web token so this is an expansion of
that second step I showed you again we
have some simpler boilerplate here not
going to walk you through all of this
right now but you just drop this in your
code and at the end of this you have a
serialized signed web token finally the
last part of our code is to turn that
into a safe to Android pay deep link and
this is what the formatted that looks
like we're going to that JWT that job is
that web token so we're gonna create the
link add the token into it and that's
the safe to Android pay deep link so to
sum up the first step was critically
programming the system
second take the user to my loyalty
signup page whether triggered from a
link a transaction confirmation as EOS
terminal and a C tag possibilities are
endless here and the last step of my
loyalty signup web page will simply
redirect to the link when
when I redirect to that link the link
will activate the safe to Android K user
experience and in a few instants the
customer's gonna have her loyalty card
on her phone look how easy that was and
then you can have chips so that's great
for getting new customers signed up but
what about the ones who have downloaded
my mobile app already so the good news
is I can use the same basic approach to
save a loyalty card into Android pay
directly from within my app we show you
a rich preview here to keep the users in
your app here we're showing plenty a
loyalty partner who is already
implemented Android pay with us and
here's what the Android pay look Android
code looks like to save this loyalty
card it's really the same thing I'm
going to end up creating a deep link at
the end of this I'm going to append my
JSON web token to the end of it and I'm
just going to intent over there let's
take a closer look at that link though
if Android pay is already installed on
the phone it will immediately invoke the
save to Android pay experience but what
if Android pay is not installed on the
phone the user will simply be to
redirect it to the Play Store to
download and as soon as the app opens
the save to Android pay experience will
complete so a lot of marketing of course
is driven by SMS and emails and we heard
that loud and clear
so we also made sure that the safety
Android pay experience works great
through these channels here's a look at
how that experience would work with SMS
you can engage your customers to save
your loyalty cards offers gift cards
directly via text message just create a
shortened version of the same safe -
Android pay deep link and then you embed
the shortened link into your SMS message
and then we've built the first-class
save experience from email as you saw
but it's the same code behind the scenes
you just create that link you stick it
in your email done finally I want to
take a look at gift cards like loyalty
cards and offers we can make these
geo-targeted so that they appear
automatically when they're contextually
relevant and when the users in your
store this way they'll be reminded they
have something to spend at your store
there are some differences here because
as a gift card but it is really the same
basic structure we're going to create a
gift card notice here that when we're
creating the gift card
I've set the type to QR code as my
Redemption that's if I have one of those
old-school QR code readers but what if I
have a cool NFC reader in my phone or at
my point of sale and what if I've
integrated with the Android pay smart
tap technology well you could simply st.
change that here your Redemption type to
smart app then you get the odd the
benefits of automatic redemption over
NFC complete with authentication and
encryption to protect the data in
transit and we're excited that Walgreens
for example has already launched NFC
smart app for loyalty cards and five
stores in AB area and I think as you
heard you'll be rolling they'll be
rolling out to 8,000 stores in the next
few months just really cool so again we
set the rest of the parameters just
eight pieces of data to plug in here
we're gonna generate that JSON web token
create a deep link at the end of this
should all be looking pretty familiar to
you now and because a lat/long was
automatic was entered at the time of
setting up the gift card class in the
first place back in that step one the
merchant console setup no further work
is required to make these gift cards
automatically surfaced when the customer
is in your store this helps you drive
engagement and keeps your brand
top-of-mind so this is just a
representative sample of all the great
merchants that are already working with
us in many different verticals for
loyalty cards gift cards and offers so
let me hand this back to Prakash to talk
about Thanks Thank You max so issuer's
our banks are another key stakeholder
for us and I'm also thrilled that many
of our partners are in the audience like
Bank of America like Discover like
American Express so just want to talk
about like how we are solving pain
points for banks so what do banks want
fundamentally they want to be top of
wallet and what we mean by that is they
want their car to be used for every
transaction where there's an in-store
transaction and if in-app transaction
transit or of an online transaction on
the web they also want drive innovative
solutions for their users and they want
to go beyond mobile banking in their
apps they want to be able to enable
their card holders to use mobile
payments from their apps controlling the
branding experience but without writing
millions of lines of code and that's
what we're trying to solve here
so how are we solving this when we make
it very easy for banks to add mobile
payments to their app and I'll show you
the user experience in the next screen
but essentially once you add a car to
Android pay if you're a bank as a bank
developer it's enabled for payment and
store in app transit online and if you
want to know more about online we have
two sessions on Friday one is bringing
seamless checkouts to mobile web and the
second is turbocharging app monetization
with Android pay so I'd encourage you to
attend those sessions so what the user
experience look like so I have my
Discover card I've launched my discover
of mobile banking app and I have an
option to add my Discover card to
Android pay and all I have to do is
verify a few details and I'm done that
card is added to Android pay so next
time I go and make a purchase I can use
that for in-store in-app web the transit
everything and I also have the option to
set it as a default so let's go a little
bit deeper how did all this happen it
happened because of this box that you
see Android pay API for issuers
now it takes care of a lot of the
headache and the pain point I talked
about because we handle everything from
tokenization with the payment networks
to generating limited-use keys to
storing them securely on the phone to
performing cardholder verification to
creating these in-app cryptograms to
handling the NFC payment protocols and
also making sure it's compatible with
the thousands of Android devices that we
have out there and their most important
thing is we do all of this but the banks
still control most of the branding and
user experience as you saw on the
previous slide and that's what we're
pretty excited about the other eight the
other thing I want to echo and this was
brought up in the previous presentation
was we are really thrilled that a number
of top banks around the world have
committed to this vision they're very
excited by the Android pay APR foresters
and they will be integrating into
Android pay from their mobile banking
app over the next few months so I'm
going to talk about one more thing and
I'm going to turn it over to max and
that's about another API we have for
issuers called card messaging so in this
example I have my American Express card
and I get a really nice reminder saying
I have offers expiring soon and I should
take advantage of that so max let me
turn this over to you sure
right so we're gonna go back to the code
for a second and talk about all that
stuff that Prakash mentioned about how
do I get my card into Android pay this
is the code start tokenization tap and
pay tokenize that's pretty much it
Android pay is going to handle
everything else it's going to invoke
that UI and start a series of activities
that's going to walk the user through
what they need to do confirming the card
details
accepting the issuer Terms of Service
getting that token cryptogram all that
stuff and at the end of this flow when
we return from this method we're gonna
be done that card will be set up for
payments so I didn't have to worry about
any of that as a developer which is
awesome and I can focus my efforts if I
were a bank developer on building a
great mobile banking app rather than
worrying about a little plumbing so of
course as Prakash mentioned I'd also
love it if people are setting my card as
their default for payments so I'll add a
method here to make that happen
tap and pay dot request select token
that's going to pop up a quick dialogue
to confirm that we have user consent to
set this card as the default and now my
card will be used whenever the user taps
so there are also a few other methods
I'm not showing here like how to query
the status of your card deleting cards
and things like that but they're all
similarly easy and it gives you an idea
of how easy it is to integrate Android
pay into your mobile banking app back to
that second thing that Prakash showed
you the custom messaging so this is a
server-side API that we have and the key
here is that with the server-side API
thanks can dynamically update messaging
in Android pay that will appear in the
card details view what you'll see here
is title double points at whole foods
and body earn double points at whole
foods aren't enjoy a one-time bonus of
40,000 miles so that message you can
appear directly in the Android pay app
next to that card on the card details
view through the server-side API so it's
a great way to reach out to the
customers and create a more immersive
of engaging experience so what's next
first we want you to try out the same to
Android pay experience yourselves how do
you do that go to gqo slash pay gift on
your phones if you do that and you come
over to our office hours which are
conveniently enough right over there at
table 1 & 2 right after the session at 4
o'clock you'll get a free Android
collectible so you can try out the save
Android pay experience yourself and then
tap and redeem it and see the whole
thing in action second come talk to us
so talk to us at the office hours we
also have office hours on Thursday and
Friday 2 o'clock on Thursday and 2
o'clock
also on Friday and we'll be happy to
answer any questions about any of the
api's that you saw here and tell you all
about it so finally we need you we need
you because Android pain is only as
amazing as all of the uses that you
create for it so with that I think we'll
wrap up we do have a few minutes for
we'll take I think about 6 questions and
we'll be able to answer them right at
the mic up here so thank you very much
no questions any please come up to the
mic yes
when is Android pay hitting the gear
mm-hmm the great question so we want to
make a great experience on watches just
like we have on phones so all we can say
is stay tuned we don't have time lines
that will you be able to publicly
release but you're gonna see the same
great experience of the watches like
you're seeing on the phones
I'm questioned about data passing and so
there's a bunch of examples where there
was data even moving from Android pay to
the device to apply it and vice-versa
from from an app to Android pay is there
additional permissions that need to be
granted or what data is allowed to go
back and forth between those two sure I
think as you saw first like users
consent so users make a choice and as
you saw when I was signing up for
loyalty it republish the information but
I had explicitly consent before it was
sent over to Chili's so essentially it's
like as you saw in that example it was
the name email and other information
that I consented to that's for the
loyalty use case sorry the question was
is it required okay yeah there - so
there are two different issues here one
is before we transmit any PII to
merchants to a loyalty signup page for
example we absolutely show that box no
matter what and you absolutely have to
click ok yes I agree the and if the user
doesn't click I agree they can still be
taken to the lowly signup page it's just
the prefilled the the form will be blank
and they'll have to the joy of entering
all that data themselves on a lovely
mobile keyboard the second part of the
question though is Android pay and
screen locks so Android pay does require
as part of its setup a screen lock and
that's fingerprint pin pattern password
those are the kind of recognized secure
screen locks that that are required to
use Android pain and you feel in few
countries is supported under play yeah
so I think what we publicly I think it
just so I'm sending a question you're
asking for countries where we support
Android pay or where we are going
okay South America so so you know I
think I want to echo what was said
earlier we want our aspiration as for
Android pair to be everywhere Android is
but journey is gonna take a few steps so
what we publicly announced is the UK of
course and Australia and Singapore
besides the US so we are looking
constantly in other countries and you're
gonna see more announcements going
forward that's all I can say
normal question time for two more
questions otherwise we'll be happy to
talk to you in a more intimate setting
out at the office hours by the way at
the office hours we'll have several
members of our team there as well who
can really kind of deep dive into any of
these areas yes
payments in the car Prakash what do you
think so again we are looking at all use
cases to make it a great user experience
we can't get into specifics about dates
and times yeah okay it looks like
there's one more question please come up
to the mic baste us terminals right so
what happens to MST based like merchants
with MST base yeah and this is and the
question is about loyalty cards or
regular payments right so at the moment
we do require for in-store experience we
require contactless technology support
for loyalty gift card offers we have a
variety of different redemption methods
including barcodes QR codes as well as
of course NFC I think we're big
believers in NFC and we're really seeing
great traction in the ecosystem there's
a lot of reter Manola zation happening
right now at merchants and we know this
is a journey but it looks like the
journeys in progress I think we're gonna
wrap it up so thank you again for coming
and don't forget to come to office hours
like we mentioned earlier and enjoy the
rest of i/o thank you